well marriage seems to be a crumbling
institution in the nineteen fifty
seventy-five percent of the population
was married today you have a majority of
people who are single which is
astonishing when you think about it
because it means that in a free country
people are choosing to be by themselves
because they don't find marriage
compelling in places like Western Europe
it's it's far worse countries like
Iceland have a 20 percent marriage
population France Russia these are all
seeing the decline in marriage
significant decline which is also
leading to the significant decline of
the population of they're experiencing
negative population growth it's not for
immigration they these are countries
that might soon disappear and they're
actually worried about it that's why in
places like Russia you have national
love day where you're getting you got a
payday to go home and make a baby
because marriage is losing its passion
and in an adrenaline-fueled 24-hour
economy I think people are gonna make
choices that give them excitement and
give them adventure and they don't feel
that marriage is is giving that to them
a couple with that is something that we
never expected and that is the sexual
famine that is to be discovered in
marriage some statistics have the
monogamous marriage at about one and
three here in America even those who
disagree say that it's about one in five
now think about that you could be a
couple in your 20s a married couple in
your 20s 30s and every night you go to
sleep together sharing a bed man and
woman no clothes on and absolutely
nothing happens that's astonishing and I
think the ones who are really paying the
price are the wives I think in our
culture we suppress and deny a woman's
true erotic nature we we seem to believe
that men are the really sexual ones and
women kind of put up with section in
order to get romantic love it summed up
in one of those humorous quotations
where marriage is the price that men pay
for sex and sex is the price that women
pay for marriage there is no truth to
this there's no truth to the stereotype
of the husband saying to his wife how
about some sex tonight honey and she
turns back and says not tonight I have a
headache
and yet the husband can have an axe
lodged in his head and he's still ready
to go precisely the opposite is true
women are much more sexual than men men
are unis orgasmic women are
multi-orgasmic women have a have a much
more deeply erotic nature think about it
women seem to have their emotions deeply
connected with their sexuality which
makes it like rocket fueled and the
suppression the denial of a woman's
erotic nature of a woman's sensual
nature is something that is depressing
the heck out of a lot of women which is
why we're suddenly discovering the
emergence of this genre of best-selling
books like Fifty Shades of Grey
no one can explain why women in a
liberated feminist age are reading a
trilogy about a guy who takes a
liberated college student and gets her
to agree to be a submissive to his
dominance in fact Newsweek magazine did
a cover story about this and why are
women reading this and the only solution
they came up with which just shows you
how shallow we are in our approach to
the erotic mind they said people are
reading Fifty Shades of Grey because
women are so over scheduled today with a
job at work and then the domestic chores
at home that they love the novel because
they wanted to give up choice they liked
the fact that Anastasia allows Christian
Grey to make all her decisions for her
in order to so that she's less scheduled
so I said to myself gosh I'll sell more
books by writing a book about a woman
who has a phenomenal housekeeper who
does all her work for the reason why
women are reading Fifty Shades of Grey
is that for many women for many American
lives that book is about the only time
they've witnessed raw lust incarnate
they're not singing in their marriages
women today are loved but they're not
lusted after they're appreciated but
they're not desired they're complimented
but their husbands aren't ripping their
clothes off and we need to go back and
understand why how is it that three four
decades after the sexual revolution
we're having less sex than ever
something went wrong and we have to be
courageous enough to understand it
because without that I think marriage is
going to continue
decline because all marriage can provide
right now for most people is stability
but it cannot provide electricity now if
we were an age that sought out stability
then marriage would be thriving marriage
would be the place where you settle down
it's where you have the domesticated
bliss of raising children but if you
live in a society where on the contrary
three 24-hour news channels are
competing against each other for
headlines people have disposable income
to go on exotic exciting vacations and
all marriage could provide a security
and stability I'm not sure that people
are gonna continue to marry at most
they're going to engage in serial
monogamy I love those words serial
monogamy they'll they'll be in a
relationship for as long as they think
the emotions can sustain them but
they're going to reject the overarching
institution that we call marriage which
solidifies the commitment the commitment
is going to be more emotional it's gonna
be why should we force ourselves to
remain together after the passion is
worn off maybe humans are not really
made for a 50-year commitment maybe they
are biologically programmed to have only
an 8 or 10 year commitments and we're
heating more and more scientists make
those that argument as well by the way
it's an argument I completely reject cuz
I actually think people are intimacy
seekers I think what we most seek is
someone to know our depth and that's not
going to come from a more casual
relationship but marriage is in crisis
I believe it's primarily because of the
loss of erotic lust and erotic desire
and it's time that we began to fathom
the erotic mind in order not just the
boast of the institution of marriage but
actually bring back a certain
electricity to the rest of life as well
you